en directo a América llegó el momento de
hablar de economía pero yo le doy la
bienvenida a mi compañero Jorge Hurtado
Jorge qué tal Muy bien Andrés Jorge
iniciamos con una tal vez la noticia del
día en la sección económica otro banco
que está en riesgo de quiebra Qué está
pasando con el crédito bueno las dudas
sobre la situación financiera del
segundo mayor banco de Suiza aumentaron
luego de que el presidente del National
Bank que es uno de sus principales
accionistas descartó aumentar su
participación las acciones del banco
Credit Suite cayeron hasta un 31% pese a
los intentos para tranquilizar a los
inversores en un mercado de por sí ya
nervioso por las recientes quiebras
bancarias en Estados Unidos las acciones
de la entidad alcanzaron un mínimo
histórico de 1,55 Franco suizos por
acción pero los problemas de Credit
Suite No son nuevos e incluyen una
condena penal por permitir a
narcotraficantes blanquear dinero en
Bulgaria también su implicación en un
supuesto caso de corrupción en
mozambique un escándalo de espionaje y
una filtración masiva de datos de
clientes a los medios de comunicación
esto hizo que muchos clientes comenzaran
a retirar sus depósitos en los últimos
meses pero lo que provocó la última
caída de las acciones fue un intento
fallido de captación de clientes el
esfuerzo parecía estar dando frutos en
enero cuando se registraron depósitos
positivos netos pero el 9 de marzo la
comisión de Mercado de valores de
Estados Unidos cuestionó este informe
anual del banco obligándolo a retrasar
la publicación luego el pánico se
extendió tras la quiebra del silicon y
el signaturbank y la situación empeoró
hoy cuando su principal accionista El
saudi National Bank descartó seguir
invirtiendo en esta empresa incluso
Credit Suite salió a pedir al Banco
Central suizo una declaración pública de
apoyo a medida que otros bancos trataban
de cubrir su riesgo de contraparte en
las operaciones con Credit suites los
precios de cotización de una ciudad de
incumplimiento crediticio a un año
pasaron de 836 puntos básicos que
indican una probabilidad de pago del 10%
a más de 3000 puntos básicos en
solamente un día esto decían algunos de
los clientes de este banco que llegaron
a la sucursales corriendo a tratar de
obtener información y otros para tratar
de sacar su dinero
todo el dinero que tengo está aquí
iré al centro para que me puedan ayudar
y les preguntaré porque no es mi país No
sé qué hacer
hoy voy a seguir las noticias voy a ver
cómo evoluciona Y sí Si veo que empeora
tendré que plantearme trasladar mi
dinero a otro banco llevo 15 años en
este banco Así que también hay cierta
confianza así que es un poco difícil
imaginar lo peor
[Música]
Jorge momento de conocer los indicadores
Los indicadores estuvieron movidos en
una jornada bastante volátil
precisamente por la que era bueno por la
caída de acciones de este banco todavía
no podemos hablar de una quiebra como
tal Wall Street cerró en territorio
mixto luego de una jornada volátil en la
que el parque neoyorquino se vio
afectado por la caída de las acciones de
el banco Credit Suite las grandes bolsas
europeas vivieron otro episodio de
pánico con el sector financiero como
protagonista el segundo en esta semana
esta vez por la por la negativa del
principal accionista del banco suizo
Para aportar más capital Milán cayó
4,61% Madrid 4,37 Londres 3,83 París el
3,58 Frankfurt el 327 y el índice Euro
stock que agrupa las mayores empresas
cotizadas ahí el 3,46% para todos los
casos Andrés fueron los mayores
descensos en lo que va de este año y en
América Latina la Bolsa Mexicana de
valores retrocedió uno coma 15% en su
principal indicador en una jornada en el
que el sector bancario continuó las
pérdidas debido a los temores de un
contagio usted mencionaba ahorita que el
banco gredith le pidió respaldo al Banco
Central de Suiza Qué dijeron ellos Qué
pasó con esa petición bueno en un
comunicado en conjunto el Banco Nacional
suizo y la autoridad supervisora Suiza
de los mercados financieros dijeron que
proveerán de liquidez a crédito en caso
de ser necesario las autoridades dijeron
que Creed Suite cumple con los
requerimientos de capital y liquidez
impuestos en los bancos de importancia
sistémica el gobierno y el Banco Central
llevan horas discutiendo la forma de
cómo estabilizar el banco después de un
día complejo Credit Suite dijo que
estaba tomando medidas decisivas para
reforzar su liquidez ejerciendo su
opción de pedir prestado al Banco
Nacional suizo hasta 54 mil millones de
dólares bueno por supuesto hubo
reacciones en Estados Unidos respecto al
Credit Suiza el tesoro estadounidense
dijo que está analizando la exposición
del sector financiero de ese país con el
banco según bloomberg los funcionarios
de esta entidad estaban trabajando con
los reguladores europeos la el viernes
pasado de silicon seguida de la
designatura Band dos días más tarde
llevó a los valores bancarios mundiales
a una montaña rusa esta semana en la que
los inversores descartaron las garantías
del presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden y las medidas de emergencia que se
tomaron ahí también quedaban a los
bancos acceso a financiamiento según
Fuentes del sector en Estados Unidos los
grandes bancos ya gestionaron su
exposición a Credit Suite y consideran
que los riesgos derivados del
prestamista son manejables hasta ahora
Bueno pero esperemos a ver cómo se mueve
el sistema bancario Jorge muchas gracias
por la información económica seguimos
con más aquí en directo América